[Musique]
bonjour à tous
à trois jours du second tour des
élections municipales nouvelle émission
spéciale ce soir sur france 3 franche
comté avec les trois candidats à la
mairie de besançon trois candidats qui
vont répondre à vos questions que vous
êtes très nombreux à nous avoir envoyé
depuis quelques jours ces candidats je
vous les présente anne vignot candidate
d'europe écologie les verts vous êtes à
la tête d'une liste d'union de la gauche
avec le parti socialiste et le parti
communiste notamment vous avait basculé
en tête du premier tour avec 31,2 pour
cent des suffrages vous êtes adjointe au
maire sortant et vous avez 60 ans
ingénieur de recherche au cnrs
face à vos ludovic fagots des
républicains votre liste est arrivée
deuxième le 15 mars 23,6 pour cent des
suffrages vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition sortant également vice
président du département du doubs vous
avez 41 ans et vous êtes principal de
collège à vos côtés eric alauzet de la
république en marche troisième du
premier tour 18,9 pour cent des
suffrages
vous êtes député élu municipal sortant
vous avez 63 ans et vous êtes médecin
bonjour à tous les trois alors madame
messieurs dans ce débat on va parler de
la vie quotidienne des bisontins de vos
propositions concrètes pour lutter
contre les incivilités développer la
culture protéger les piétons et les
cyclistes ou encore généralisé l'accès à
internet haut débit
mais d'abord l'actualité du moment c'est
l'occupation du chantier du futur
écoquartier dévêtent depuis une semaine
des activistes se sont installés dans
les jardins qui doivent accueillir un
peu plus d'un millier de logements sur
une trentaine d'hectares sur ce projet
très polémique qui sera au sommet de la
pile des dossiers à traiter pour le
prochain maire de besançon vous avez les
uns les autres
je dois vous le dire parfois manqué de
clarté aussi je vous demanderai des
réponses très précises
on rentre dans le vif du sujet en
avignon avec cette question d'yves
pourquoi vouloir continuer le projet
irréaliste des bêtes déjà une première
chose c'est que ce projet là puisqu'il
pose question nous avons nous sommes
engagés à faire en sorte qu'il puisse
être remis sur la table
données les données factuelles par ce
qui en fait en ce moment il ya beaucoup
chiffre qui circule et c'est donc on a
besoin de remettre transparence
connaissance maîtrise du dossier pour
que les habitants entendent les enjeux
de ce dossier là ce dossier là c'est
lutter contre l'étalement urbain c'est
proposer des logements avec une
diversification du type d'habit terres
d'habitat
c'est aussi prendre soin à la
biodiversité aux écoulements d'eau sur
des eaux superficielles
nous avons des enjeux importants sur ce
dossier-là and video il mettra sur la
table
construire howett ou pas je dis que ce
dossier là il est nécessaire que l'on
puisse construire le long du tram mais
ce dossier là il sera mis sur la table
pour que tout le monde comprenne quels
sont les enjeux et comment on le fera on
va soumettre ce dossier là à des
scientifiques aux citoyens et on
regardera très clairement comment lutter
contre je le redis l'étalement donc ça
amènera des constructions ça amènera des
aménagements de ce dossier là et ça
amènera ce que ce dossier là soit
compatible avec les enjeux du 21e siècle
la biodiversité
la question de l'eau et la question de
la qualité de vie ça amènera des
constructions donc si vous êtes maire
dimanche vous construirez howett
si on met gros gros prennent bien je dis
je le redis sur un certain nombre de
secteurs de cet endroit là on devra
construire si toutefois demain et
scientifique me disent ce n'est pas
possible parce qu'en fait on ne peut pas
rendre compatible la construction et la
biodiversité de ce secteur
mais encore une fois on ne pense pas
l'urbanisme à partir d'un seul quartier
je suis géographe
j'ai travaillé sur l'environnement
depuis des années et donc on travaillera
en connaissance de cause
monsieur fagots question de paul émile
quel sera le coût de votre projet terra
maison sur howett sur le projet térabits
anciaux qu'on a chiffré à 5 millions
d'euros
c'est quand même une question
fondamentale que cette question à des
bêtes j'ai toujours pas compris vraiment
la réponse de madame vigneault
en gros la réponse et les binaires
voulez-vous bétonné ou ne pas bétonner
les bêtes aujourd'hui
bonjour aujourd'hui jeudi ferrand je ne
sais pas ce qu'il en est sur notre
projet terra maison sur moi je suis très
à l'aise parce qu'en plus c'est une
question qui me passionne vraiment ce
qui se passe sur sur les met donc moi je
refuse on a toujours refusé cette
bétonisation sur les bêtes qui a été
porté par les par les élus de la
majorité sortante juste derrière juste
pour remettre les chiffres sur les jours
donne la parole pour préciser on parle
de 7 hectares constructibles sur 23
hectares aujourd'hui 24 opposé voilà
donc à peu près 30% constructive je vous
redonne la parole
donc en fait si vous voulez sur ce
projet terrab et sociaux donc on est
très à l'aise parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
on veut vraiment arrêter ce projet donc
de bétonisation des bêtes on a toujours
été constant et cohérent par rapport à
notre engagement là dessus et ensuite
c'est de pouvoir faire en sorte de
développer une ferme urbaine avec une
production locale et de travailler sur
ce qu'on a appelé nous cette cité
durable cette cité durable avec des
espaces pédagogiques avec des espaces
éducatifs pour les bisontines issiaga la
petite ferme qui exigent non non je
connais très bien le secteur n'ont pas
si vous l'avez deviné fado jeu juste
terminée par un pot règne dans ce cas
dame vignes où je vais pas bien que vous
complétez votre réponse parce que lors
de la conférence de presse commune avec
alexandra cordier dissidente la
république en marche qui vous a rallié
au cours de il ya quelques jours au
futur effectivement alexandra cordier
est résolument favorable à la
construction de l'écoquartier
vous avez dit lors de cette conférence
de presse finalement nos positions sont
très proches avec alexandra cordier donc
je suis un peu surpris il taira besançon
vous ne parlez pas de logement il n'ya
pas le mot logement dans votre projet
est ce que vous vous construisez ou
est-ce que ce projet là c'est de
l'affichage
alors si vous voulez par rapport au
soutien qu'alexandra cordier m'apporter
apporte à notre liste besançon
maintenant vous l'aurez constaté ce
n'est pas une fusion de listes
tout simplement c'est un soutien et nul
besoin aujourd'hui d'être d'accord sur
tout pourquoi reporter un projet un
projet commun rapport à cela vous
construisez n'eut besoin d'être d'accord
sur tout pour pouvoir construire un
projet commun demain vous l'avez bien
constater aujourd'hui nous ce que nous
voulons collectivement c'est de faire
rayonner besançon et par rapport à la
construction
oui il y aura du développement donc de
l'habitation raisonnée parce que là
dessus
moi j'ai toujours j'ai toujours été très
claire par rapport par rapport à cela et
non pas des immeubles comme alain
vigneault on voudrait pouvoir développer
sur sur le secteur des bêtes mais
derrière si vous voulez aujourd'hui
alexandre accords vont m'apprendre
questionné par rapport à cela alexandre
accordé apporte son soutien parce
qu'aujourd'hui entre le pragmatisme elle
déraisonnable d'un côté entre si vous
voulez le renouveau et la décroissance
je crois qu'aujourd'hui même cordier a
choisi le pragmatisme et le renouveau
eric alauzet lundi la semaine dernière
sur ce plateau vous avez été le plus
clair sur les bêtes vous avez dit oui il
faut construire parce que sinon on
envoie les nouveaux habitants à la
périphérie
le problème c'est que c'est pas votre
programme monsieur à l'oser votre
programme s'est tiré au sort des
citoyens qui décideront parce que les
politiques et les experts
considérez-vous sont disqualifiés est-ce
que vous préjugez l'avis que rendra la
convention citoyenne que vous souhaiter
convoquer j'ai une petite idée de ce qui
peut en sortir
sur le fond moi j'ai ma vision du
territoire
il faut partir du projet existant qui a
été travaillée qui ne s'occupent que 30
% de l'espace
il faut l'améliorer par ce qu'il s'est
passé quinze ans mais ma responsabilité
de maire c'est de proposer des logements
de qualité aux habitants des logements
qualitatif écologique avec des espaces
privatifs terrasse rez-de-jardin ouvert
sur la nature des espaces logement qui
respire sinon les habitants vont partir
à la périphérie et c'est pas parce qu'on
a des logements vides à besançon qui
sont malheureusement pas qualitatif
toujours peut pas toujours les rénover
sont dans des quartiers ou mal configuré
les gens veulent pas forcément il y
aller la preuve c'est que on a stagné au
niveau des habitants à besançon s'est
accru à la périphérie
déjà on est déjà en difficulté alors que
dijon a réparti ses habitants entre la
périphérie et le centre ville
donc c'est extrêmement important de
construire mais de bonne qualité voilà
donc mon projet est très clair après la
convention citoyenne c'est pour arriver
à un consensus
merci
finalement nous sommes très proches les
trois parce que je pense que j'entends
qu'il ya des trucs sur les vaches
allaitantes vous discutiez avec les
habitants d'installation d'une
production agricole en vous discuté avec
des habitants de symbole
ils sont ils sont pas contre les les
constructions à rien si on avance et on
a compris on a compris mais vos
positions sont très nuancée à tous et
d'autres justifier sur justifier leurs
éléments très concrets
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous avez quand
même votre numéro 36 de votre liste qui
dit clairement il faut bétonner les
lettres puisqu'il s'est exprimée par
rapport à cela et il dit très clairement
que les bêtes se le projet des bêtes
c'est de l'écologie champ m enfin je
crois qu'à un moment donné il va falloir
comment bien en avance je voulais dans
ce débat valérie on passe au patrimoine
et à la culture s'il vous plaît valérie
vous dit churchill disait un peuple qui
oublie son passé n'a pas d'avenir que
comptez vous faire pour valoriser le
grand passé historique de besançon eric
alauzet je vous donne la parole
oui la richesse de besançon c'est son
patrimoine se son patrimoine
architectural historique littéraire tout
le monde connaît victor hugo bien
entendu et d'autres ne serait-ce que la
place victor hugo on à la victor hugo
qui étaient là les frères lumière
charles nodier est donc ce haut de la
boucle c'est l'acte à tous les trésors
de notre histoire depuis granvelle
jusqu'à la porte noire
je veux en faire le coeur vivant et
battant de notre notre belle cité et le
coeur touristique la partir de là c'est
un tout un projet de valorisation de la
cites delà de l'ascension vers la
citadelle ce que la citadelle se
conquiert comme historiquement en a
gravi sens et pas par des téléphériques
télécabine qui sont allés loup à la
distance de la ville et qui éloigne les
touristes ça c'est les manger bien sûr
bien sûr cette sainte anne c'est un non
sens voilà donc deux portes en place
commencer par les places revaloriser la
place sarrail la place victor hugo et
faire de la la boucle
la boutique citadelle on a une petite
boutique ans mais il faut absolument que
les touristes les visiteurs passent par
lebouc et redescendre par la boucle
c'est notre projet anne vignot une autre
question mais un peu similaire comment
comptez vous faire pour la sauvegarde et
la mise en valeur du patrimoine bâti à
besançon c'est une belle question parce
que quand on parle du centre ville on
non pas leurs armes en deux on parle de
la citadelle pour le tourisme par armand
de la qualité du centre-ville que l'on a
et donc on a besoin d'engager un
urbanisme qui rénovent qui rénove le
centre-ville qui apporte encore plus de
qualité dans le bâtiment mais surtout si
qui valorise qui valorise ce centre
ville ce centre ville qui est qui et
renaissance qui est libre donc comment
le valoriser davantage
et bien c'est tout un projet touristique
qui doit se mettre en place
qui doit à pouvoir travailler et sur
justement le sens que peut avoir le
centre-ville
souvent les gens viennent à la citadelle
rentrer dans la ville et découvre qu'en
fait elle est magnifique
ce travail là n'a jamais été fait donc
il est urgent que nous proposions un
projet qui soit liée non seulement
patrimoine bâtiment mais où matrimoine
naturel et on a un projet d'écotourisme
que nous voulons développer qui met en
avant et l'histoire patrimoniale du
centre ville et toute la qualité du
grand besançon ludovic magaud sur cette
question du patrimoine écouter sur le
patrimoine aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
notre mémoire et c'est ce trésor partagé
pour les bisontines et les bisontins et
nous allons nous en avons pleinement
conscience si vous voulez mais vous êtes
arrêté un instant sur sur la citadelle
qui fait partie de ce patrimoine on
pourrait parler aussi de tout secteur
protégé et le secteur sauvegardé qui
fait aujourd'hui plus de 270 hectares
sur le territoire bisontins qui est ça
va du quai vauban abattant en passant
bien sûr par le centre ancien mais sur
la citadelle la citadelle voilà dix ans
dix ans qu'elle est inscrite au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco est la
paperie un visiteur on est passé de 240
mille visiteurs à 240 milles visiteurs
et dont ils ont tous leur mère dimanche
aujourd'hui il va falloir vraiment lui
redonner vraiment ses lettres de
noblesse à cette citadelle c'est pour ça
que d'installer un vrai continuum entre
le coeur historique les prix de vaud et
la citadelle par cette télécabine qui
fait cette saison mais c'est un projet
vraiment global touristique qui aura
aussi un retour sur investissement pour
l'ensemble de notre territoire et ça
c'est un élément majeur parce que nous
souhaitons vraiment avec l'équipe de
besançon maintenant donner à besançon
cette dimension touristique qui sont
aujourd'hui ça serait transformé les
près de lure où un parking
c'est ça la valorisation de la rivière
nous avons une rivière man il utilise
pas qu'on n'utilise pas et donc il est
nécessaire
dans organiser l'ensemble justement de
son aménagement
par exemple kassamen pourrait très bien
et c'est andré pendant six ans pour
poser des actions en rapport à ce camp
vous ne savez pas ce que je peux dire en
son sein de nos équipes
mais en tout cas ce que je propose là
c'est l'avenir et l'avenir c'est
envisagé par exemple que casa men
reçoivent un espace pour les
camping-cars parce que nous avons des
touristes de la nature qui veulent aussi
s'installer pendant quelques jours sur
notre centre ville
eh bien nous représenter qu ils seront
pas auprès de vous ils seront basculés
prédault c'est déjà un projet culturel
sportif en soit on en a besoin de ce
projet paraît bien sûr où la danse est
bien un ensemble à bercy la lame
politique qu'il faut voilà un
porte-monnaie opposé en avoir énormément
de questions sur la sécurité et plus
spécifiquement les incivilités du
quotidien qui gâche un peu la vie des
bisontins stéphane par exemple quelles
mesures proposées vous pour lutter
contre le bruit les voitures les motos
et les incivilités tac déchets
déjections canines
eric alauzet je vous écoute je pense
qu'on a un problème d'état d'esprit
qu'il faut restaurer à la fois de
réussite pour chacun
donc faut accompagner chacun pour la
réussite il faut accorder chacun pour le
respect mutuel et donc l'éducation était
la priorité de mon projet il faut
réapprendre à chacun à nos enfants au
contact des adultes les éducateurs les
enseignants les politiques les policiers
tous là où on est à lutter contre toutes
les formes d'incivilités
ça va du bruit que vous indiquez aux
jets d'objets sur l'espace public
et ça ça veut dire que toute la société
se mobilise pour qu'on restaure le des
règles on réapprenne les règles qu'on
les rappelle les règles et de la
sensibilisation des répercussions de
super meute et avec les policiers
municipaux avec les parents j'ai prévu
des contrats de parentalité
quand des enfants font des bêtises voir
des incivilités et bien qu'on puisse
être au corps à corps avec les familles
avec des parents avec un éducateur il ya
une association de jeunes étudiants qui
s'appelle la fève
ils sont une centaine bénévoles chacun
s'occupe d'un gamin il s'insère dans la
famille il attend pas les enfants les
parents il faut presque partie de la
famille il accompagne à l'éducation il
sait départ a retrouvé la parentalité
extrêmement important anne vignot les
tags l'affichage sauvage
bruit quelles sont vos propositions je
suis d'accord il faut rétablir un
certain nombre de règles de respect des
deux les espaces publics le respect des
uns des autres et pour ça il faut
rétablir des commandes hier des
relations on a besoin de retisser des
liens avec les familles avec les jeunes
adultes
et ça ça peut se faire autour de projets
autour de l'école ça peut se faire
autour des projets autour du sport
autour d'eux les maisons de quartier
donc ce lien là il faut leur tissé ces
urgentissime nous avons besoin de dire
qu'à besançon par la considération qu'on
a pour les familles et les enfants et
les adultes
nous avons du coup la possibilité de me
changer radicalement la façon de
fonctionner et pour ça je voudrais
monter un certain nombre de projets
collectifs avec les personnes c'est eux
qui alimenteront pour donner plus de
sens dans la relation les uns avec les
autres
ludovic fabre je les ai toujours dit
pendant cette campagne que je serai
vraiment le maire de l'ordre républicain
c'est-à-dire de la plus petite des
incivilités jusqu'aux actes de
délinquance qu'on a pu connaître ces
derniers temps ça fait partie de notre
programme je crois qu'à un moment donné
il faut qu'on arrête aussi avec avec cet
angélisme aussi du quotidien
on a une ville qui est magnifique d'un
point de vue architectural apparaître
d'un point de vue patrimonial mais qui
est malheureusement salle elle n'est pas
sale du fait du travail des agents qui
le font bien mais ils essaient les
salles parce que nous avons des
incivilités au quotidien donc nous avons
mis en place et nous mettrons en place
dans le cadre donc du doublement des
effectifs de la police municipale unités
une unité donc de lutte contre les
incivilités et où nous mettrons aussi en
place des mesures de responsabilisation
tu dégrade tu payes tu des gras tu ne
peux pas payer mais par contre tu peux
réparer et je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui quand un principal de
collège en le mettant en place
aujourd'hui au quotidien je peux vous
garantir que les affame les familles
accompagnent cette démarche-là réaliste
un doublé lors du succès à 10h03
quotidien sans excès
justement c'est voter c'est pas possible
j'ai justement monsieur on a donné une
session de cours donne la parole aux
spécialistes des spécialistes des coups
de menton oui monsieur fagots départ
d'une agressivité mais ça fait fin de
campagne mais gardez votre vraiment
non mais parce que changent pas d'avis
éviter ces fous moi qui vais faire moi
je ne change pas d'avis et notamment
vis-à-vis des travaux mais à chaque fois
les stops s'il vous plaît monsieur
fagots a été interpellé sur le
doublement de la police municipale
bénédicte vous demande comment monsieur
fagots souhaitent ils financent et le
doublement de la police municipale elle
donne un chiffre 1,6 million d'euros par
an or en année pleine le chiffre est pas
tout à fait exact il a même au delà
puisque aujourd'hui a quand même un
constat très précis la ville de
perpignan qui a autant d'habitants que
nous c'est 1,2 faux l'asim la question
c'est combien d un habitant alors qu'à
besançon on est à 0,5 policier municipal
pour 1000 habitants on est en déficit
par rapport à cela
donc aujourd'hui en année pleine dire
une fois qu'on aura recruté nos
cinquante policiers municipaux
supplémentaires ça sera deux millions
d'euros qui seront portés par les
collectivités où vous prenez l'argent
c'est un choix politique puisque faire
de la politique ce sont des choix
d'orientation budgétaire
et comme on est limité parce que on est
dans un budget et que on est limité ça
veut dire que si vous mettez plus de
policiers c'est un choix politique c'est
un choix politique que j'assume tout
amener ça veut dire que vous enlevez
ailleurs du coût des médiateurs on
parlait tout à l'heure de la médiation
vous pouvez de l'animation r&d pas dire
ça on enlève des personnes qui sont dans
l'est dans les musées qui sont dans les
bibliothèques etc et qui réduisent l
attendait 100 mille euros
je vous dise g20 le budget monsieur je
vous parle de la gestion
parce que si en plus de ça vous êtes
dans une contradiction totale
vous étiez le premier à dire à l'époque
de fillon qu'il fallait réduire les
coûts en matière de fonctionnement cette
histoire des services publics 1 classe
et ce soir allez vous répondre et on
donnera la parole à eric alauzet public
attendu mais sans seulement vous vous
étiez vous souhaitiez cette gestion là
avec beaucoup moins de personnes qui
sont pas parlementaires
moi je parle de moi c'est ça qui nous
intéresse sauf s'il vous plaît on a la
parole à eric alauzet la demande depuis
tout à l'heure où est raisonnable
sérieux dire les choses telles questions
il ya 63 policiers municipaux
c'est invraisemblable de pouvoir les
doubler et c'est invraisemblable
également de confier des missions de
travail sur l'incivilité à un effectif
réduit c'est tous les policiers qui leur
s'occuper d'un sibilité avec des arts
été renforcées vidéos etc
je les amendes si nécessaire et puis
faut être soi-même exemplaires quand il
ya une date qui s'installe à besançon et
qu'on ne condamne pas la zad monsieur
fagots en l'espèce parce qu'il a un
projet totalement irréaliste howett
il cautionne le désordre alors c'est
bien de faire des grandes déclarations
de vouloir faire celui qui va être ferme
mais dans la réalité je ne vous ai pas
entendu condamner la zad vous qui est le
tenant de l'ordre c'est innovant mais
parce que vous avez un projet qu'elle
tentait là qu'on dirait qu'à l'eau s'est
fait l'interprète que vous voulez faire
plaisir à répondre
madame de ouvre les portes du 2 litres
d'une sagot est-ce que vous condamnez
l'occupation par des activistes en de
deux éléments par rapport à ça enfin je
crois qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur à l'oser vous avez passé de
postures vraiment d'être méprisant je
veux bien me voulait plaider sans je
vais répondre parce qu'un homme est déjà
en avance sur vos deux concurrents sur
le temps de parole parce qu'il est temps
aussi de rétablir un triple fonction
autant aller sur le fond moi je n'ai pas
rallié sur le fond mais allez sur les
valent surtout avec malice et l'ont
laissé le reste en dessous inaporc
installations si on avait laissé leur
répondre eric alauzet ce n'est pas de
mon fait mais vous en dise aujourd'hui
ne me donnais c'est vrai sont allés vous
avez d'une agressivité on comprend un
sens nous coupent les micros à tous les
deux il va perdre et vraiment vraiment
votre sang-froid simplement sur les
bêtes aujourd'hui c'est pas de mon fait
c'est du fait aussi des deux élus qui
sont ici aujourd'hui ceux qui
s'installent sur les bêtes c'est pas
entendable une zad aujourd'hui qui se
positionne ce n'est pas entendable et ça
n'a pas sa place donc mettions d'année
location mais du fait du fait de qui du
fait de ce qui suit des trousses
aujourd'hui du fait dans ce qui se
défausse et qui disent c'est pas moi
mais assumer aussi l'événement ce que
vous allez porter la verrie galzi
monsieur fagots parce que vous avez un
projet qu'il légitime ce type
d'occupation et autres préoccupations
quotidiennes des bisontins le transport
et le respect des trottoirs et la
protection des piétons tome vous dit
concernant le stationnement et les
infractions routières continue-t-on le
laxisme ou à picton enfin la loi après
l'élection eric alauzet excusez moi
monsieur chevreuil par non vous étiez en
train de boire alesi je me laisserais
pont neuf si vous voulez vous et
reformulé s'il vous plaît concernant le
stationnement les infractions routières
continue-t-on le laxisme ou à picton la
loi après l'élection ce que j'ai dit
précédemment sur les règles sur le
rappel des règles ça vaut pour tout ça
vaut pour les petits comme pour les
grands d'incivilités voire voir les
délits de
il ya des règles peut-être que certaines
ne sont pas bonnes auquel cas on les
revisite mais ya rien de pire que
d'avoir des règles qu'on ne respecte pas
et donc je pense que le début d'un
mandat quand il y 20 ans le même maire
le nouveau maire qui arrivent il faut
que les choses soient claires avec lui
et si vous êtes élue dimanche vous ferai
respecter
vous mettrez des amendes aux voitures
qui sont sur les trottoirs et qui ont
bien les pièces jointes et rustre vie
normale beaucoup d'un tract du centre
ville ça ça passe par le respect des
règles que les gens puissent déambuler
en sécurité avec les poussettes avec les
fauteuils albino une autre question la
ville n'est pas fait pour l'autonomie
des enfants il n'est pas envisageable de
laisser son enfant ou son jeune
adolescent se déplacer seul en vélo ou à
pied tant la circulation est invasive
que ferez vous pour rendre la ville aux
enfants qu'ils ont raison et ça rejoint
là la question qui est posée là plus
personne aujourd'hui ne respecte les
trans les trottoirs les pistes cyclables
la circulation personne ne respecte 30 à
l'heure le vin à l'heure sur la ville de
besançon chu de la faute à qui la faute
c'est la faute au fait qu il faut
aujourd'hui moi je le dis ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qu'on va faire
lundi lundi quand on sera si je suis
maire j risque dans la rue on ira voir
les personnes il faut qu'elle change
d'habitude parce que l on trop pris
l'habitude dire allez voir il y aura les
verbaliser on ira les verbaliser on ira
leur dire comprenez qu'ici quand vous
êtes ici vous empêcher les personnes sur
le trottoir à circuler avec les
poussettes avec des fois des difficultés
déplacements sur les pistes cyclables
vous le fait déporter les personnes sur
la route sur la route vous ne respectez
pas les vitesses tous les jours on a des
personnes qui disent c'est 30 à l'heure
nos enfants on se demande tous les jours
s'ils vont pouvoir un jour apprendre à
traverser la rue sans prendre de risque
oui c'est urgent il faut faire respecter
les règles et on a besoin de la police
municipale mais aussi la police
nationale ludovic fagots sur cette
question et je vous demandais des
réponses courtes parce que vous êtes en
avance sur le temps de parole si vous
êtes très court effectivement les
voitures et je crois qu on se rejoint
par rapport à cela les voitures qui
n'ont pas leur place sur les trottoirs
et qui empêche les personnes à mobilité
réduite de se déplacer ce n'est pas
entendable et donc elles n'ont pas leur
place
par contre aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
problématique par rapport aux
professions libérales par rapport aux
entreprises au centre ville
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas entendre que
des entrepreneurs ne puisse pas venir
faire des travaux parce qu'ils se font
verbaliser je sais pas si vous avez déjà
eu une fuite d'eau à votre cumulus
mais quand le plombier vient ou quoi que
ce soit il ya bien falloir qui se
stationnent quelque part avec son
outillage donc il ya un vrai travail à
mener en travaillant aussi sur les
espaces de livraison pour pouvoir faire
en sorte aussi que nos entrepreneurs et
nos professions libérales évite d'être
verbalisé au quotidien autre soucis du
quotidien pour les bisontins soucie
encore plus prégnant pendant le
confinement l'accès à internet haut
débit
nous avons beaucoup de questions
notamment pour vous madame vigneault
henry vous demande pourquoi vous refusez
le déploiement de la 5g à besançon le
déploiement la 5g à besançon aujourd'hui
il est remis en cause non pas dans dans
le fait de déployer il est remis en
cause dans le fait qu'on ne connaît pas
encore les risques que l'on pourrait
encourir
nous avons aujourd'hui le gouvernement
lançait un sénateur des républicains qui
dit nous n'avons pas suffisamment
d'information fasozine technologiques
pourraient exposer l'ensemble de la
population
il est urgent de faire des études qui en
mesurent les effets donc je tiendrai un
principe de précaution parce qu'il est
on avance très souvent sur la
technologie sans savoir ce que l'on fait
stéphane vous dis madame vigneault par
excès de prudence envers le progrès ne
risque-t-on pas de voir les entreprises
s'implantèrent ailleurs le progrès il ne
l on a démontré avec le co vide que le
progrès un moment donné nous a amené à
arrêter toute l'économie
je tiens quand même à ce qu'on se
rappelle de ce qui vient de nous arriver
à force de dérivés en matière d'écologie
on a vu se développer une crise majeure
qui a été une crise sanitaire et cette
crise sanitaire nous a amené à une crise
économique
on a tout arrêter du jour au lendemain
on va continuer à avoir des dérives de
ce type là qui permette qui disent le
libéralisme nous permet tout et on
réfléchit après on veut réfléchir avant
on veut faire des études avant et savoir
pourquoi on déploie ses technologies le
4g
on peut déjà faire beaucoup de choses
eric alauzet frais prendrez-vous un
moratoire sur le déploiement de la 5g si
vous êtes maire dimanche avec le vrai
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas la 4g
partout donc on apprenne d'équité des
territoires y compris dans
l'agglomération je ne parle même pas des
territoires ruraux
donc on a une responsabilité collective
à ce que l'ensemble du territoire avance
en même temps donc déjà mettons de la 4g
partout mettons de la fibre partout et
puis il ya un débat d'une controverse ça
fait partie des sujets y compris au
gouvernement
faut il voir accepter les controverses
si l on l'a vu dans le mobile comment
les scientifiques ont hésité donc fondre
à ma question ai-je pu voir ou pas à
votre question parce qu'il faut
continuer pour des expérimentations pour
voulait attendre les quotas enfin le
rapport de l'homme cesse leurs amis les
rapports mais vous savez même le rapport
de l'ansés s ne tranchera peut-être pas
le jeu je connais beaucoup de sujets
comme ça qui traîne depuis des années et
qui ne sont pas tranchés voilà donc
prudents mais 4g partout fibre partout
les juifs de vic fagots le principe de
précaution vous roule bayel vous le
balayer d'un revers de main et
inévitablement parce qu'aujourd'hui si
vous voulez la recette qui est quand
même le régulateur des télécoms a
démontré qu'il n'y avait pas donc défait
par rapport à ça vous avez vous évoqué
des éléments excusez moi mais c'est pas
mon régulateur des télécoms et de faire
des études sur les conséquences et la
mise à la jambe
vous avez l'âge entre les fréquences
aussi qu'il ya eu plusieurs organismes
l'agent des fréquences la nfl il a quand
même évoqué par rapport à cela
moi aujourd'hui si vous voulez les
décroissants et madame vigneault qui
dans cette décroissance
ils veulent vraiment libéré il dit il
veut vraiment limite les limites et les
libertés des uns et des autres nous on
est pour l'innovation
on est pour le progrès et aujourd'hui
oui vous avez raison monsieur alauzet il
faut déployer déployer davantage la
fibre avec des problèmes quand même
technique d'infrastructures au
centre-ville mais aussi il fournit des
réponses orthez sur la 4g et la 5g
qu'elle garantit que nos impôts et la
dette ne vont pas augmenter ses meunier
qui vous pose la question je vous
demande une réponse courte est clair à
tous les trois eric alauzet déjà je veux
dire nos concitoyens qu'ils ont observés
en trois ans les bisontins une
suppression progressive de leur taxe
d'habitation
ça fait 600 euros en moyenne on dit
jamais on revient jamais sur les bonnes
nouvelles donc la taxe d'habitation est
supprimé pour 80% des bisontins l'impôt
sur le revenu pour la classe moyenne on
parle toujours de la classe moyenne est
aussi en processus de diminution
ça c'était c'est important de le dire le
contexte localement je m'engage à ne pas
augmenter je dédie les impôts localement
sachant que tous les ans la loi de
finances augmente du tout et la dedd
pardon et la dette a mais la dette c'est
une autre affaire la dette la question
portait sur les deux sens ça n'a rien de
voir la dette il se trouve que là nous
rend con
une situation terrible tout le monde n'a
pas mesuré la gravité de la crise
économique qui arrive ça va se
manifester à l'automne en particulier ce
sont des événements qui arrive une ou
deux fois par siècle
c'était l'après guerre et c'était la
crise de 29 c'est cette raison pour
laquelle je dis toujours qu'il faut bien
gérer les collectivités collectivités
locales l'état pour faire face le moment
venu à des crises comme celle ci donc
dans la période il va falloir s'endetter
pour faire tenir les entreprises et
préparer la transformation économique
écologique sinon ça va s'effondrer
ludovic fagots à écouter sur cette
question concernant la fiscalité
l'endettement je crois qu'on a montré
aussi nos preuves au niveau du
département tant que vice président du
département aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
augmenté les impôts nous avons aussi
fait en sorte de continuer à investir
massivement et à désendetter aussi la
collectivité on a de l'expérience par
rapport à cela
mais au niveau des choix budgétaires du
département certains vous reprochent
d'avoir fait le choix budgétaires de
supprimer les mots doux pas bon donc ça
bon au détriment non mais vous voyez ça
c'est une ancienne rhétorique qui
n'existe plus par rapport à ça
simplement sur les mots doux puisque
vous me encore une fois je pense que
j'ai de la constance par rapport à cela
si vous voulez aujourd'hui dommage que
la ville n'ait pas saisi la main tendue
du du département et puis dommage aussi
c'était pas un arrêt c'était simplement
un report d'une année donc ça me l'a pas
simplement pour fermer la parenthèse par
rapport à l'euro a expliqué de la nation
vous avez mis quatorze questions voilà
vous connaissez mais concernant la
fiscalité serait zéro augmentation merci
anne vignot les impôts alors je crois
qu'on ait fait tourner tous sur le fait
que les impôts on n'y touchera pas on
n'y touchera pas en dehors du fait
qu'ils aient un taux qui monte de façon
un peu mécanique en particulier aux à la
loi de finances qui est voté au
parlement mais sinon pour la question de
l'emprunt
je suis très content de l'entendre que
certains disent qu'ils vont aller sur de
l'emprunt puisque c'est ce qu'on nous
proposions parce que nous avant d'avoir
le coc vide on nous avions envisagé
d'être c'est les impôts de demain
non c'est pas les impôts de demain non
mais non non je suis désolé mais non oui
la question c'est d'investir pour
l'avenir donc on assure on avait déjà
envisagé d'aller sur une 10 millions
d'euros pour les écoles nous avons aussi
la capacité de désendettement c'est à
dire une gestion de la dette qui est
plutôt raisonnable qui est considéré
comme vertueuse même par la cour des
comptes qui peut nous amener engager
encore une dizaine de millions d'euros
sûr je parle du budget de la ville parce
que je parle pas de l'agglomération on
est là pour la dernier pour la ville
d'accord donc du coup là on peut aller
aider peut-être aujourd'hui plus sur la
deux volets économiques qu'on ne l'avait
pensé au premier tour premier tour où
vous voulez aller sur l'énergie
renouvelable sur des pistes cyclables
sur des enjeux king rona piste et donc
sur deuxième tour et le deuxième tour on
va regarder ou est ce qu'il faudra
mettre le faire le bilan en particulier
on reparlera avec la culture parce qu'il
faudra peut être sans doute qu'on en
aide
la culture a su bien supporté la crise
dans laquelle il merci marie monsieur
fagots votre allié monsieur allenbach
associés madame vigneault à la milice
vichyste tous les coups sont il permet
pour gagner
écoutez là je crois que je vais être
très claire par rapport à cela
monsieur à lembach a fait donc une
affiche moi je les ai appelés
personnellement je vais demander qu'il
la retire parce que je pense que ça
n'avait pas sa place c'est pour ça
qu'elle a été retirée dès le lendemain
dans la vitrine
je crois qu'il ya des comparaisons qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être donc voilà c'est
d'accord est clair mais c'est sa raison
que ça tient il fait pas partie de ma
liste
il vous demande monsieur josé pourquoi
ne pas avoir retiré votre candidature au
profit de l air avec le risque de
l'extrême gauche mais ça n'existe pas ce
scénario où est ce qu'on a vu oui alors
sur l'extrême gauche d'accord donc sur
les alliances lrm l air et ça existe à
20% qui se retire mais ça ça n'existe
pas d'ailleurs ça n'a jamais existé
monsieur fargo a fait semblant une mise
en scène pour essayer de séduire les
électeurs qui avaient voté pour moi qui
sont pas très content d'ailleurs de son
de son attitude c'est assez peu assez
peu républicain en 'core rate' il
propose une fusion il a évoqué ses mais
ça même pas été le cas cette façon nos
listes sont trop peu éloigné une fusion
vous auriez pu en disant mais au moins
on aurait été mis devant nos
responsabilités mais ça n'a même pas été
le cas c'était je n'avais pas dégagé
dégager de l'espace vous n'avez pas ces
changements et du mépris
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce que
jamais je n'aurais osé faire une telle
proposition
monsieur vague ou d'ailleurs nous listes
sont très proches et on va stresser pour
ça les choses pour ça que vous avez des
candidats actifs c'est ça qu'on taxe les
candidats sur la liste serait de 6 fihri
à la beauté pour nous mêmes nos
stratégies de campagne donc voyez comme
quoi il ya des prises de responsabilité
qu'ils répondent les techniques de
campagne quand vous ratez le directeur
ce qu'elle faisait au droit quand anne
vignot effectivement c'est revenue
régulièrement pendant la campagne
etes-vous l'extrême gauche alors on
découvre de que depuis plus de 20 ans la
gauche est installée à besançon
toutes les gauches même le parti
communiste parce que en fait on va se
dire les choses
souvent c'est ce sont les communistes
qui sont visés et les communistes ils
ont participé au développement d'un
certain nombre de politiques
je tiens à revenir par exemple sur la
gestion de l'eau qui autour de ces
tables serait en capacité de dire qu'une
politique est porté par des communistes
à besançon est une mauvaise politique
la preuve c'est que l'ensemble de la
communauté urbaine a opté le principe
d'aller sur c'est régis sur l'eau donc
on voit que lie à un moment donné et
c'est nationale c'est pas à besançon
c'est un des éléments de langage qui
sont utilisés par en particulier les
républicains avaient soumis pour montrer
suis dressé comme la frange de travail
suffit d'ouvrir la peau à la france
insoumis c'est pourquoi goji de vix à
l'aude sur quoi vous basez le soir du
premier tour madame vigneault a été très
clair en disant je suis prête à
travailler avec la france insoumise si
c'est un secret c'est un secret de
polichinelle aujourd'hui que vous avez
essayé de faire liste commune vous n'y
est pas arrivé vous êtes entendu les
deux victoires on laisse répondre parce
que là vous l'annoncer dans le projet
qu'on lit là la nature du nissan réalité
les lis qu'on a connus de gauche a
besoin de plus 60 ans n'aurait pas mis
les transports gratuits n'aurait pas mis
le revenu jeunes qui est un début de
revenu universel n'aurait pas mis
l'accueil inconditionnel des migrants et
ses biens liés à la constitution de la
liste mana vigneault qui est parti très
très très à gauche je laisserai pas
vraiment et après on avance dernièrement
oui moi je le répète
reprenons notre projet alors sur la
question de
transports en commun dans d'une partie
de gratuité je tiens à le dire c'est
toute la france aujourd'hui qui se pose
la question et pas seulement des listes
de gauche se sont tous les to les toutes
les villes qui veulent aller sur des
plantes climat air énergie qui soit
positif pour que massivement les gens
utilisent les transports en commun et
donc tous les leviers sont utilisés
analyser et la partie que nous nous
donnons c'est transports en commun
gratuits le samedi transports en commun
pour les moins de 26 ans je pense qu'on
reprendra le temps de l'expliquer mais
c'est juste qu'on est dans une
caricature gratuité partielle gratuité
qui permettent de faire évoluer le
comportement des nettoyants merci
beaucoup
nicolas vous dis monsieur fagots en 2012
vous avez fait campagne contre le
mariage pour tous en tant que future
mère célèbre rêve ou des mariages
homosexuels
oui c'est clair merci d'avoir fait cours
vont changer ou si vous monsieur fagots
c'est tant mieux je vous félicite parce
que je suis droit dans mes bottes je ne
change pas donc c'est bien on écoute et
changez vous avez super-g support à toi
monsieur buisson oui bon argument est
mort une fois votre alter et non mais
c'est démodé votre rhétorique abrite au
rythme des journées aujourd'hui moi ce
qui m'intéresse que tu sais danser
besançon moi qui m'intéresse
autre question vous dites besançon
m'intéresse le plus monique vous demande
et ça rebondit sur une attaque dont eric
alauzet et l'auteur lors du dernier des
doigts monique vous demande monsieur
fagots élus mr habib trévoux besançon
alors encore une fois donc des
spéculations et des rumeurs ont circulé
tout le monde a fait référence à saône
et moi je vous le dit c'est une raison
qu'on a acheté avec mon épouse il ya
plus de douze ans maintenant quand
j'étais principal adjoint au collège
dawson donc je pense qu'on fait
référence à cela on nous avons notre
appartement à besançon donc je vous aime
soyez clair vous vivez ou besançon et il
ya des week-ends on est sûr sur saône
vous êtes nos employés d'envoyer ses
angles et là dessus il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de souci sur la cour vous êtes
réinstalla stone en 2017 pas de soucis
messieurs chapeau monsieur phase où il
essaie de parler pour empêcher de parler
non mais je nouvelle chef ait repoussé
les inscrits sur les listes électorales
à saône en 2017
il est venu se réinscrire à besançon en
2019 au dernier moment donc je ne sais
pas quel continent
rien n'empêcherait nos objectifs ces
maires de saône pour les bisontins on
peut en douter
sa sé on peut aussi en fonctionnement
non pas du tout je veux dire je vais
vous dire que là dessus pour n'est
qu'une gêne par rapport à cela sûr que
si je pense qu'on a écrit à trois jours
du second tour que se tait vous dire aux
bisontins encore indécis avant le
scrutin de dimanche je vais vous donner
à chacune et chacun 40 secondes pour
conclure évidemment j'ai oublié l'ordre
du tirage au sort c'est eric alauzet qui
commence merci d'être plus je connais
bien besançon gelé repentez de dans tous
les sens à travers mais mes différents
mandats on a deux enjeux
le premier c'est le risque du
déclassement de besançon est impératif
de remonter besançon ii catégorique aux
bisons sont invisibles et fort le 2
c'est un question de compétition des
territoires le deuxième c'est le fait
que besançon doit participer avec
l'ensemble du concert des villes
mondiales à la coopération pour changer
de modèle économique un modèle plus
résistant aux crises
donc c'est la compétition et la
coopération quand mes deux adversaires
sont sur l'un ou l'autre ont du mal à
faire la synthèse entre les deux et on
le fait parce qu'on est central qui
réunit le centre gauche
le centre-droit les écologistes donc
nous sommes prêts nous sommes forts nous
sommes concret nous avons beaucoup
d'ambitions pour cette ville anne vignot
votre conclusion s'il vous plaît eh bien
écoutez dimanche moi j'appelle les
habitants bisontine et bisontin a en
toute connaissance sein de connaissance
de la nécessité de transformer notre
ville en une ville écologistes une ville
qui est solidaire et attractive à voter
pour notre rassemblement écologiste de
gauche et des citoyens et encore une
fois face à une droite qui n'a cessé de
nous caricaturer nous attaquer allant
jusqu à nous traiter de vichyste malgré
tout nous avons faibles c'est-à-dire
sans nous avons fait le choix de mener
notre campagne sur des propositions très
concrètes et sérieuses et donc pour
besançon je compte bien sûr sur la
mobilisation parce que nous serons nous
à côté du citoyen
ludovic faire votre conclusion s'il vous
plaît nul ne reste insensible de toute
manière aujourd'hui un charme de
besançon et et notre belle ville se
distingue à la fois par la richesse de
son patrimoine par un environnement
d'exception par ses savoir-faire
horloger c'est microtechnique et puis
ses capacités d
innovation et tant d'autres choses
capitalisons aujourd'hui il me semble
important de le faire sur nos valeurs
défendons nos atouts qui sont uniques et
nos intérêts soyons fiers de besançon
respondi un sur deux bouts besançon nous
l'aimons et voulons une ville bien plus
attractive avec l'ensemble de l'équipe
de besançon maintenant nous voulons
vraiment et nous affirmons clairement
cette nécessité aujourd'hui d'un réel
changement
écrivons une nouvelle page pour une
ville de tous les possibles et assurant
le présent et je pense que ce dimanche
28 juin
ne nous trompons pas d'avenir merci à
tous les trois merci également à toutes
les équipes de france 3 franche-comté
mobilisés depuis dix jours pour vous
faire vivre chaque soir sur notre
antenne la démocratie locale naudy débat
y compris celui ci sont à revoir en
intégralité sur notre site internet vous
donne rendez vous dimanche soirée
électorale à partir de 19h dès 20h nous
donnerons en exclusivité le nom du
nouveau maire de besançon vous faire
vivre toute la soirée avec les élus les
battues en attendant vous retrouvez
aussi dans un instant pour l'information
en région profitez bien de votre soirée
sur france 3 la chaîne des municipales
merci
[Musique]